how surprised were you here that you
mentioned as a preferred candidate to be
the next entry to the Washington press
news I'm not worried about that to be
quite honest with you you're the first
person to mention it to me in a public
setting so about the same I'm giving you
you know guys I'm I'm the court I'm the
head coach of a one-in-four football
team that's going on the road to play a
Hall of Fame caliber quarterback with my
third quarterback you think I'm worried
about anything this week other than that
that's Mike Tomlin coach of the Steelers
on his tuesday press conference and
Chris look it's significant for what he
said and for what he didn't say because
this is a this a big deal when you have
a guy who's the coach of a team and he's
under contract beyond this year being
asked about possibly coaching another
team you would expect a little more what
are you talking about this is my job
I've been here since 2007 I am NOT
leaving here this is where I am instead
he just kind of sidestepped it like it
was just some trivial matter it's not a
trivial matter it speaks to the heart of
whether or not he's gonna be the coach
of the team after this season and I just
I expected him to go a little bit
farther with it to slam the door on the
possibility and he didn't which tells me
the door isn't slammed what are you
crazy were you listening he said he's on
going on the road with a third string
quarterback against the Hall of Fame
quarterback he's not paying attention to
it he's telling you he's got bigger
issues Chris Bosh is a bigger issue this
is not a bigger issue than that okay to
the heart of his job I have a job I love
my job I've been here for 13 seasons now
I'm not going anywhere until they tell
me to that's the kind of answer that I
would expect and look he knew that it
was coming he said you're the first
person who's asking that question in a
public setting so he knew that it was
out there he had a chance to think about
what his answer was gonna be and I don't
think these guys who deal with the press
all the time just blurt things out
without having a plan I think everything
that every coach says is or at least
should be calculated and when he doesn't
say that's a ridiculous question I'm the
coach of the Steelers and I'm
to continue to be the coach of the
Steelers and I'm not coaching any other
team this is my team I that surprised me
that he didn't go that far
well I mean I feel like he basically
said that though so and then the other
thing too is we're predicating this all
on dots being connected because Bruce
Allen was in Tampa and Mike Tomlin was
down there in Tampa as I was there at
that same time too and we're not that's
how it works so well yeah works and I
think we're all sitting here going well
Bruce Allen's his butt is hotter than
any butt in America right now so no yes
yes because we came to the conclusion
over the past couple of days while you
were doing something else that that
Bruce Allen is the surrogate owner in
Washington oh the conclusion so we'll
just assume everything then and just go
down the road okay Kris if he's still
employed now after going 42 and 75 over
the last 10 years what makes you think
anything's gonna change it over the
balance of the season because he's still
there the season and that's when the car
talks about Mike Tomlin will come about
and then Mike cow and just told you he's
worried about what he's got to do this
week so I think we're making a lot out
of nothing at this point I understand
people connecting the dots but I thought
he slammed the door shut with what he
said that's all I don't think he did I
don't think he did and and and I think
that Bruce Allen's presence or absence
from Washington doesn't change whether
or not dangerous Snider would be
interested in Mike Tomlin I think the
fact that there's a prior relationship
between the two guys makes it easier to
sell Tomlin on Allen still being there I
think Allen's the impediment to getting
an A List coach and I think if Tomlin
would be gone from Pittsburgh after this
year if they go to in 14 or something
like that and everybody decides it's
time for a change I think there'll be
another team out there that Mike Talman
would rather go coach than Washington
because of all the dysfunction in the
organization unless he can convince
himself that he's the one who can fix it
no I don't disagree with that statement
at all I mean yeah I'm with you I think
that yes if it comes down to Mike Tomlin
being fired there in Pittsburgh that
there will be teams that are interested
in him and that I would think you know
those other teams are more appealing to
him as well
now the other factor is his he is from
that DC Virginia area so I
understand people connecting the dots
there too because that's that's a pretty
big dot right well okay okay so so I was
but but nothing he said is leaving you
to bully like you're trying to make
something out of what he said Chris and
he's a woman never Chris Chris
he's never gonna say I'm interested he's
never gonna say anything to suggest he's
like you're trying to assume he say
anything else
no I'm telling you if you're a thicket
think of how Bill Belichick what hand to
a question like that
Bill Belichick does nobody will be right
look at my lips nobody
[Music]
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports